un an après la sortie des états unis la
russie se retire du traité ciel ouvert
le président russe vladimir poutine a
validé ce matin la fin de cet accord sur
la surveillance aérienne suite au vote
favorable de la douma on retrouve en
direct de moscou notre correspondant
antoine gayraud antoine bonjour c'est
officiel le ciel russes ne sera plus en
libre accès où il aura tout à fait
c'était la dernière étape du processus
une étape franchie dans la matinée par
vladimir poutine qui vient donc validé
le retrait de la russie de ce texte un
texte qui permettait des vols de
surveillance militaire au dessus des
territoires des états signataires c'est
donc la douma il ya deux semaines qui
actait de 7 cette décision et vladimir
poutine a donc apposé sa signature sur
ce décret dans la matinée décision prise
en réaction à la décision des états unis
de sortir de ce texte était donc l'année
dernière une décision prise au final en
novembre 2020 je propose de voir un
extrait de ce décret signé ce matin par
vladimir poutine
les etats unis se sont retirés du traité
sous un prétexte fantaisiste ce qui a
bouleversé de manière substantielle
l'équilibré entre les intérêts des états
membres du traité atteint avec sa
conclusion
cela a porté un préjudice considérable
au respect du traité et à son rôle dans
le renforcement de la confiance et la
transparence et entraîné une menace pour
la sécurité nationale de la fédération
de russie en raison des dites
circonstances la fédération de russie a
pris la décision de se retirer du traité
la décision initiale avait été donc
prise dans un premier temps par donald
trump avant d'être confirmé en mai
dernier au mois de mai par son par son
successeur
joba y donne ce que regrettent les
autorités russes pour la porte parole de
la diplomatie russe la russie a tout
fait pour sauver ce texte écoutait les
etats-unis et leurs alliés n'ont pas
répondu aux propositions de la russie
visant à préserver le traité ciel ouvert
les efforts de la russie visant à
préserver le traité n'ont trouvé d'écho
n'ya washington ni dans les capitales
des pays alliés des etats-unis alors que
les pays signal
r soutenait le traité ciel ouvert et
déplorait la décision de donald trump
ils se sont quand même associés à
l'évaluation selon laquelle cette mesure
prise par les états unis étaient
justifiées ce décret d'aujourd'hui vient
donc entériné cette décision ce dossier
un énième point de désaccord entre
moscou et washington alors que dans
moins de 10 jours vont se rencontrer
vladimir poutine et joe biden à genève
antoine claireaux en direct de moscou
merci pour toutes ces précisions